ah there we go
thanks Maggie hey is Ed Harris nominated
for anything tonight you know
ah no I don't think so okay all right
then we can take the stool with us when
we leave look at all these people out
there dressed up looking sharp thinking
about how much sex they're gonna have
with each other later Ted what are you
talking about man
look all right I'll come clean with it I
just want to be a part of it come on you
guys please just tell me where it's
gonna be look Ted no one knows what
you're talking about okay Mac the big
post Oscars Hollywood orgy please tell
me where it is look I think your
imagination has gotten out of control
dude what come on you guys I'm really
good at sex and I can bring sodas and
snacks and and soap and stuff please all
right it's at Jack Nicholson's house
yeah yes all right here are the nominees
for best sound mixing Argo John Wright's
Gregg roubloff and Jose Antonio Garcia
lame is Iran
Andy Nelson mark Patterson
Life of Pi Ron Bartlett DM Hemphill and
Rukia
Lincoln Andy Nelson Gary Rydstrom and
Ronald Jenkins Skyfall Scotland
Ricky Russell and Stuart local and the
Oscar goes to
lame is Arab Andy Nelson
Hey
Academy Award nomination
thank you so much water what an amazing
honour to receive this tonight the night
that Oscar celebrates musicals it's
fantastic a huge thank you to Tom Hooper
a director amazing cast that brought all
the passion in the heart of this story
to the screen we thank you so much
Cameron Eric Deborah working tightly new
versal thank you all and from Simon mark
and myself huge thank you